hello welcome to this video this is a
new glitz game Bobby's truck 1 yes and
then start on that waiting stuck and
struck it seemed I really have to get to
something decent again but yeah just
have to play and see what happens
nothing much you can do just try to play
well and things will fall into place ok
I'm playing this double of Yankee no
here black now where's the choice is c5
d5 all kinds of sensual setup no they
often do c6 in such a position no that's
something that I had on the board quite
a lot I think it's awfully good idea for
black to just play Bishop g4 and trade
stuff trade on f3 the an IBD 70 here
there are a couple of options Knight c3
is one of them just getting the night
developed ok I'm going to take
and maybe night to be 5131 attending 95
we're going to play a 6m know that looks
weird I think but we'll see
okay I'm just going to grab this Bishop
down see a taffy and this insists that
much Bishop a three maybe quickly played
as Europe looks very weird put the Queen
on e6 so if i take on the eight I can
also play Knight g5 when you have to go
to gphone it looks strange green the
Queen's you funny and now this one
rattling Bishop f3
[Music]
or bishop age three in some cases you
know yeah whatever I had an idea with
that so we just give me the coin that's
nice of him give me the Queen can't just
trade everything here take on g five and
now let's do a count queen for 2 minor
pieces ok
is the thing I'm getting this he foul he
has to trade check hmm just a moment
down not taking is okay now check it's
really loud and sound I'm just taking
the porn spam black resign yeah yeah he
is ably ignored what i was doing ok and
i don't know so he ran that a couple of
options d for Quincy to this is also
move I think probably Quincy to Lewis is
better at c5 I'm not sure that this is
so so great for me to allow that that's
it certainly okay from black air for
whites but nothing special yeah I played
before I was thinking you should just go
a six and then the question is what I'm
doing next maybe I'm going deform than
95 but it's not nothing nothing special
but this is just helping me I mean I
have distant as both ideas a six ism
like I don't care move I mean I go to
these things anyway i can never Bishop a
three and now it gets tricky already
really tricky like this one match five
yeah and now after age 40 ok it's
already losing i am a tree well I didn't
see a good move either but I mean age
six like extremely ignorant like what
are you doing
H formed exactly without an idea so here
the twin gets lost yet and you just have
to have to trade stuff now and it's
fairly generally easy to to win this so
somehow he did not really I mean this is
a pretty obvious that DNT just
encouraged all the moves I want to play
anyway so that was really a little bit
strange ok guys thanks for watching